Herkese merhaba arkadaşlar hepinizi
sevgiyle kucaklıyorum bugün burada size
buluşmamızı sağlayan Alara ya teşekkür
ederek başlamak istiyorum çok vakit
kaybetmeden de konuya gireceğim Sağolsun
arkadaşlar da bir tattım İki gay yaşam
amacı konumuz bu sağ olsun bu davete ben
kendi yaşamını gözden geçirmiş olduğu
biraz mesaj ettim size bunlardan
bahsedeceğim aldığım notlar da ilk
Sorduğum soru hayatta yaşama adım
atarken yaşamak sadece nefes almaktadır
Bence değil yaşamak daha soyut bir
kavram hayatta olmaktan daha önce bir
kavram bir şekilde herkesi şekilde
hayatta kalıyor yemeğini yiyor Bunlar
temel ihtiyaçlar ama yaşamak böyle mi
ruhumuz bunlarla mı oluyor bu soru çok
önemliydi benim için sizin yaşınızdayken
hayatın kendisine kapılıp bir yerlerde
savrulup giderken
İyi dersler ne bulmuşken birçok şey
bulmuşken Çok düşünme fırsatım olmuyordu
Kendi hakkında Ama bir gün Hayat öyle
bir yok ki birşey yaşarsınız ve bir anda
sizi düşündürmeye başlar 18 yaşındayken
Bir kaza sonucu tam dondurma koparıp
ameliyattan Uyandığımda bir arkadaşımla
gelip bana demedi şimdi kişilerin
Birazını bana verdiği vs bu mümkünmü
diye bir soru sordum kendime ve Bugün
bir yere kadar insanların olduğunu ve
bir yerden sonra yalnız oldu o gün
Aslında sorular sormaya başladı Ben ne
yapıyorum istediğim şeyler bunlar mı
bunlar beni mutlu ediyor munzurlu muyum
kendimle barışık mıyım bu çok önemli bir
konu kendimi seviyor muyum onları
sorduktan sonra düşünmeye başladım aklı
hayatı daha başka izlemeye başladım
Yapmak istemediğim yapmaya maruz kaldığı
durumlar oldu ve bunlar bana ne iş
değil mi Evet o kadar önemli bir nokta
ki bu hemen bir insan yaşamını bulamaz
ağız deneyimler size ne istemediğinizi
söyler Bu da ne istediğinize ne yapmak
ne yapmaktan hoşlandığınız da sizi
götüren bir yoldur bu yaşamaya böyle
devam et amaç aramaya başladığında da
sanırım 18 19 yaşındayım ama çorap bak
da bugün görüyorum ki amacı bulmanın bir
parçası yolun bir parçası biraz sancılı
bir süreç acılı bir süreç erdemin yolunu
acıdan geçer misali ama değiyor Yani
şunu da söylüyorum kendime bir amacı
olmalı mı yaşamını Bence olmalı Çünkü
böyle mutlu oluyorum Belki olmayabilir
başkaları için Onlara da saygı duydum
Elif çok önemli bir durum var arkadaşlar
öyle bir dönemde yaşı
ve kendinizle Baş başa kaldığımız çok
zor çünkü en basitinden tek başına
kaldığımız yerde cebimizde bütün dünyayı
açılabileceği miz bütün insanların ne
yaptığını görebileceğimiz sosyal medya
var İnternet var bir ama bir avantaj bu
aynı zamanda bir dezavantaj çünkü en
sağlıklı cevaplar en sağlıklı sorular
insan kendiyle baş başa kalacaksın
soruluyor ve düşünülüyor ve bunu da
örneklemek istiyorum kendi yaşamından bu
süreçte de her gün engel olamıyordum
düşünmeye için kararıyor endişeleniyorum
soruyorum ben ne yapacağım ne olacak
Sonra bir gün şöyle birşey oldu 10 sene
sonra ben nerede olmak istiyorum 10 sene
sorma hayal ettim ve O hayalin de bir
ihtimal hoşuma gitti biz aklıma bir anda
Çocukluğum geldi çocukken yaramazlığı
bıraktık bir çocuktum
o yuvada pisler vardı orada böyle
alıyorum mitinginde şu yorum için huzur
kaplıyordu ofis hatırladım ve o an karar
verdim ben bu yoldan gideceğim bunu
tartmadan etmeden çok hızlı bir kararlı
benim için ve hemen eyleme döktüm o
zaman Marmara Üniversitesi'nde
okumaktayım Turizm Otelcilik bölümünde
hiç bana Uyan uymayan bir bölümü ve
bunun da farkındaydım hemen oranın
tiyatro bölümü kulübüne gittim hiçbir
şey bilmiyordum yetenekli miyim değil
miyim yapabilir miyim kullan hepsini
cevabı bunu deneyim dedikten sonra geldi
biraz yapabildiğim gördüm hala bana
sorarsanız yetenek bilmiyorum ben
kelimeyi söylediğimde etmekten gelen bir
kelime Siz bir şey yeter biliyor musunuz
sanırım böyle etmek için de çalışmak
gerek bir kitapta karşıma çıkmıştı 11
saat
Bu bir işte uzmanlaşmanın kuralı 11.11
saat Bu arada şunu da belirtmek isterim
meslekler hakkında konuşuyoruz benim ben
meslek olarak görüyorum yaptığımı Benim
varoluş nedenim bu şekilde var oluyor
bir oyuna prova yaparken kendini
keşfediyorum çok hoşuma gidiyor bu
başkasını bitmeye bilir başka bir şey
olabilir hepimizin içinde bir hazine
olduğunu düşünüyorum ama hazine'nin
içinde bambaşka şeyler olduğunu
düşünüyorum ve şu an bunu bulamamış
insanların da içinde hazine var sadece
oraya gidip Tipo kendinize gerektiği
yerde kavga edip kendinizle ilişki
kurmaya başladık o kapıyı açma
cesaretiyle o kapıya kapağını hazinen
açtığınızda karşınıza gelen shiva Umarım
bunu bulursunuz Bu da dediğim gibi bazen
istemediğinizi yaptığınızda de
istemediğiniz
ne oluyor Hayat bir şekilde siz oraya
yönlendiriyor Yeter ki hayatı dinleyin
bahsettiğim gibi bu düşüncede bunu
çözdüğünüz de bu iş bitmiyor bir eylem
süreci var eyleme geçince de bitmiyor
Yani bu yaşam amacı bir süreklilik bir
süreç hala devam ediyoruz 16 yaşındayım
kaç yıl geçmiş üstünde ancak on yıl
sonrasını düşünüp on yıl Geriye
baktığımda Evet kendimi gördüm yerdeydim
Çünkü çok emek verdim Emek vermek bu
kadar önemli ki arkadaşlar sevdiğiniz
işi emeklerin sevdiğiniz işin ne
olduğunu çok bir önemi yok Yok neyi
seviyorsunuz başkaları çok ters gelen
şeylerin ise bilirsiniz burada Tabii çok
önemli ettik ve insan olabilmek bunu
insanca yapabilmek saygı çerçevesinde
yapabilirim Ve şunu görüyorum ki Aslında
emek verirken ben varılmak istenen
noktaya gidildiğinde değil
ama oraya giderken sana demiyorum yolda
öğreniyorsunuz sürekli öğretiyor ve şunu
fark ediyor insan öğrenmek çok keyif bu
öğrenmekten kaskın didaktik değil yaşam
size didaktik bilgisi olmuyor böyle
cümle cümle şeyler söylemiyor bir şey
yaşıyorsunuz bunun üzerine
düşünüyorsunuz bir deneyim elde
ediyorsunuz müthiş bir duygu Benim için
o yüzden tuvalet mi çok seviyorum
Özellikle meslek için söyleyim
Mesleğiniz sizin hayatınızın çok büyük
bir bölümünü kapsayacak O yüzden
sevdiğiniz Belki o bilir yapmakta mutlu
olduğunuz işi meslek haline çevirirsiniz
bambaşka iç içe girmiş Lig olacak
hayatınızda da para odaklı düşünmeyin
yani şu an benim gözlemlediğim gençlerle
ettim sohbetler
O yüzden için Keşke yüz olsaydık Çok
mutlu olurdum para odaklı düşünülüyor
çok para mutluluk getirir gibi bir
yanılsamalı bir cümle var Hayır bir yere
kadar mutluluk getirir kendinizi
keşfetmenin mutluluğu hiçbir şey de yok
Bana sorarsanız Bir de zor kelimesini
çok duyuyorum ben bu yolu seçtiğimde zor
sözcüğünün çıkardım sözümden onun yerine
rağmen koyduk ama böyle demek yerine
buna rağmen demeyi seçtim Bu da ister
istemez sizi bir savaşçı çeviriyor Çünkü
hayat Evet evet Her zaman pozitif her
zaman negatif Çok karmaşık bir yapıp
ayak size kendi bildiği gibi geliyor ve
Sis hayatı kontrol edemez
Bu ancak kendimizi kontrol edebilirsiniz
hayatın getirdiklerini uygulanıp bunları
Kendi kararımız da kendi faydanıza
çevirebilirsiniz bahsettiğim şey manevi
bir ayda adlı bir fayda değil o yüzden
zor sözcüğünün sözlük lerimizden
çıkarmaya davet ediyorum sizi
hayatınızda renkli olacak kesin
gençliğin en büyük avantajı önümüzde
koskoca bir yol var kontrol edilemez bir
enerji var siz amacı bulduğunuzda o
enerjimiz oraya yönlendiririz Bu da çok
keyifle ve dinle diyorsunuz burada
pozitif olmak veya negatif olmak değil
kendinizle baş başa kaldığımızda Nötr
bir yerden olabildiğince baktığımızda o
zaman sanki önümüzde bir de var 6 kum
yavaş yavaş duruluyor ve o görün O
denizin evini görmeye başlıyorsunuz
Gönül görünüz
de yaklaşıyor burada çok önemli bir
durum var paylaşmak İnsan bir yere kadar
kendini dışarıdan bakabiliyor
dostlarınızla yaptığınız paylaşımlar
sizin kafanızda çok güzel kapılar
Açabilir Sizin düşündürebilir bir Kanlı
canlı delikanlı dedikleri zaman sadece
bu cinsiyetçiliği kavram değil kadın
için de erkek için de geçerli insanın
kanı Kaynar Bazen çok sağlıklı düşünemez
Ama bu paylaşımlarda baktığınız zaman o
geniş yolu çerçevelendirme istediğiniz
gibi sizin elinizde ve bu paylaşımlar
sizi düşündürecek bir de çok güzel bir
durumunuz var Saçmalama lüksünüz var
hata yapmadık işimiz var yakın korkmayın
en büyük korku korkudan korkmak Hata
yapmaktan koptuğunu zaman ebata
yaparsınız baktığınız zaman kendi denize
bunu göreceksiniz Korkma Hata yapmaktan
Saçmalama lüksünü kullanın saçma sorular
sorun bu
O çok saçma sorular çok büyük icatlar
yol açar bu kendinize Emek vermek o
kadar önemli ki arkadaşlar Siz kendinize
Emek vermezsiniz size İnsanlar bir yere
kadar emek vereceğiz ama siz kendinizi
Emek verdikçe kendinizi oluşturmaya
başladıkça yaşadığınız duygular tarihsiz
olacak Akşamları yatağınıza girdiğiniz
de uzun duyacaksınız 15 saniye sürebilir
yukarı Baba hadi buraya gelene kadar bu
Mevsimler Gibi insanın içinde mevsimleri
var Bazen kuş olacak bazen yaz gelecek
bazen Bahar gelecek bazen hiçbir şey
olacak Burada Önemli olan vazgeçmemek
Ben mesela bunu kendime çok sordum
düşecek vazgeçeyim içim el vermedi ve
vazgeçsem yapacak bir şey bulamadım
Belki bulursam bu yoldan vazgeçebilirim
bu yola girdiğiniz zaman yol size
bu ne yapmamız gerektiğini söylüyor Ne
okumanız Neye çalışmanız bunu söylüyor
yol Size yeter ki yolu dinleyin Bu Yol
sizin içinizde bu içinizdeki oldu bu
Hayalinizdeki yolunu dışarıya
döndürdüğünüz de bu yol gerçekleşiyor bu
mucize değil de ne her zaman insanların
mucize beklediğini gördüm Halbuki Aynaya
bak Gözlerinizin içine bakın birazcık mı
düzleri göreceksiniz dışarıdan değer
beklemek Evet Herkes kendini değerli
hissetmek istiyorum şunu soruyorum Siz
kendinize değer veriyor musunuz
kendinize Değer verin kavga eden
kendinizle Barış'ın asla küsmeyin
Kendinizden vazgeçmeyin arkadaşlar
kendimizden vazgeçtiğinizde her şeyden
vazgeçmiş olmuş bu çok önemli çok kötü
zamanlarımızda bile Efendimiz'in için
izin kalbinizin
O çocuğun bile bırakmayın bazen dediğim
gibi amaca giden yolda istemediğimiz
şeyler yaşayabilirsiniz şöyle düşünmek
lazım bu uzun vadeli bir yol Bugün size
36 yaşındayım derken zamanın gerçekten
nasıl geçtiğini algılamış değil Bunu
bana hep söylerlerdi sizin yaşınızda
Kemer algılayamadım sizinle algılayamama
ihtimalimiz var Bir yıl çok büyük bir
zaman gibi görünüyor ama bakın annemi
başladı Bir yıl bitti Mart ayındayız
nasıl geldik Bilmiyorum özellikle böyle
belirsiz dönemler için Geleceğe dair
sorular sormak Sizin bir şey sokabilir
böyle durumlarda size tavsiyem gününüzü
doğru değerlendirmemiz bugün doğru
değerlendirirsiniz Geleceğiniz doğru
işaretlerseniz ve bugün yaşadıklarımız
ve çıkışımız da aldığımız karar ver
O yüzden geçirdik Deniz O zaman bugün
yaptıklarınızı geleceğimiz olacak
arkadaşlar Bu size son sözüm düşünceden
eyleme geçip cesaret anahtarı kullanın
belirsizlik insanı korkutur boşluk
insanı korkutur fakat bir yandan da çok
iyidir boşluk her şeyi alabilecek
algılayabilecek ailemizle siniz dir Bu
boşluğun rehavetine kapılıp bu boşluğun
Sizdeki güzelliğini fark etmek ve bunu
size heyecan vermesini sağlamak size
hayata daha fazla bağlayacak Umarım
yolumuza biraz Işık tutabilmek içindir
bir Keşke yüz olsaydık sorular sorup yok
yapsaydık enteresan videomu Bilgisayar
ekranında sadece insan kendine göre
izlenmesi daha ulaşamadım açıkçası biraz
süre her bir dönem um
bir gün karşılaşırız ve ve Sizler Hayat
hikayenizi ayak amacınızı bulmuş
kendiyle başlık neşeli ve etrafına Neşe
saçan insanlar olmuştur Hepinizi çok
öpüyorum teşekkür ediyorum